our mum believed that young people have
the power to change the world
she believed in your strength because
she saw it day in
and day out and in the faces of young
people exactly like you
she witnessed a boundless enthusiasm and
passion
prince harry honors the young people who
are carrying on the legacy of his late
mother
princess diana i want to thank you for
being part of this
important moment and for being such a
valuable asset to your community
the duke of sussex made a surprise video
to address the latest recipients of the
diana award
for their humanitarian work and
community action
i'm truly honored to be celebrating your
work your commitment to change making
and the vital role that you've taken on
representing a new
generation of humanitarianism later this
week
my brother and i are recognizing what
would have been our mum's 60th birthday
and she would be so proud of you all for
living an authentic life
with purpose and with compassion for
others the 36 year old royal
also mentioned his wife meghan markle
meg and i fundamentally believe that our
world
is at the cusp of change real change for
the good of all
and he wrapped it all up in a sweet
inspiring little bow
never be afraid to do what's right stand
up for what you believe in
and trust that when you live by truth
and in service to others
people will see that just as they did
with my mum
as harry mentioned he is set to reunite
with his brother prince william
at a small event to mark the unveiling
of a statue
they commissioned in honor of their late
mother on july 1st
what would have been diana's 60th
birthday
this event in july is is much
anticipated
the unveiling of the diamond statue is
going to be an
important date it's firmly cemented in
both of the brothers calendars
a source previously told et that harry
is now back in the uk
at frogmore cottage the windsor
residence where he and his wife lived
before stepping away from their royal
roles in early 2020.
of course this all comes amid the royal
family's effort to repair their internal
rift
following prince harry and meghan
markle's explosive interview with oprah
winfrey earlier this year
diana always said to them boys stay
close
don't ever fall out she'll be devastated
that that is what happened
and she would be wanting them to feed
her together for that unveiling of the
statue in her honor
a source also previously told et that
megan will not attend the unveiling of
the statue
since she just gave birth to their
daughter lillabet diana
earlier this month meanwhile royal
expert katie nichol told
et in april that while harry and william
still have a long way to go when it
comes to repairing their relationship
being together for the unveiling of
their late mother's statue
is a step in the right direction the
idea that
harry's suddenly going to come around to
william's way of thinking and vice versa
i think is is a way off i think there do
need to be
more conversations there's clearly still
a lot of hurt
a lot of resentment and a degree of
mistrust
i think on both parts so it's early days
but i think the hope is that
come july when we are hoping to see the
brothers stand
once again shoulder by shoulder to
unveil the statue in memory of their
mother
that the relationship will be stronger
and in a better place
you